gimont se font au
je m'appelle daniel logos et la religion
c'est la forme physique et rien de tout
ça serait arrivé si j'avais pas voulu
changer de vie mais l'idée de travailler
quarante années de plus en survêtement
m'était devenue insupportable
monsieur dans la bo est ce que vous
consommez des stéroïdes
tu crois qu'ils m'ont accusé ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est notre spécialité si
on est de vrais magiciens du pénis je me
suis fais moi même j'ai fait beaucoup
d'argent vous auriez dû ont dépensé un
peu en salade
je savais quelle honte et la salade
un pauvre type
s'il n'y a pas des ailes t'as jamais eu
envie d'améliorer ta vie et d'huile non
je me sens bien ici c'est vrai les
poissons des faits je voulais dire en
général c'est quand la dernière fois que
paye et on vous y attend
j'ai un plancher ce qu'il faut faire tu
as fait ton temps mon vieux plus au bord
et tu cherche du travail
il tapait un cas et tu oublies bonnessée
total boeing
bien sûr qu'on peut victor que scheider
audi criminelle
j'accepte ont fait de mal à personne
compromis équitable c'est lui
oui cette peur en effet signé lui fait
boire une boisson protéinée on lâche un
vrai jeu d'enfant
j'ai regardé un tas de films paul je
sais ce que c'est le gage du saint jean
vient d'acquérir avec succès tous
bougeant ses actifs qu'est ce qui va se
passer maintenant je dois me charger d
faut que je trompe base i way est bien
quand ça fait mal que 50 à l'est
continue
j'avais dit pas de violence et je le
pensais quand je lui ai dit je jure
devant dieu que je ne tuerai personnes
c'est l'état quand ce sera terminé on
irait tous en camping d'accord